hey look at ronnie with the new vegas
look he's got the big handlebar mustache
when i spoke to you on the phone i was
going to bust your balls a bit because
like you were like this is so great man
it's so great you're enjoying it i don't
know why that bothers you no no you
could admit that a hundred it's gonna be
100
it's hot i know it's hot yeah but at
night it's beautiful
no when the sun goes down it's only 107.
i'll play a couple of clips of ronnie's
saying goodbye to his house in new york
before he left that was weird leaving
that house it was yeah sure every memory
he had was related to sex i bet
all right we're going in the bathroom
this is where i piss this is where but i
don't [ __ ] here because i [ __ ]
downstairs i like the toilet downstairs
better why don't [ __ ] break my balls
about this ronnie any fond memories from
this bathroom oh yeah [ __ ] went down in
here showers showers sink or not in the
sink but i came up behind you a couple
of times
if you could explain to the listeners to
explain i came up behind her she was
standing here naked at the sink that's
as far as i'm going with this part of
the story that's it the shower what if
the walls could talk there's shower it's
got all the heads to spray on your [ __ ]
and your dick and everything else
stephanie uses it sometimes she uses it
for uh she sits on her little seat and
gets herself off goodbye shower can't
wait to get out of here
then then you say goodbye to the kitchen
listen to this
what room is this what what do you mean
what room is this you can't tell it's a
kitchen or the people listening with the
yeah like the people can't see a
refrigerator and a [ __ ] stove in a
sink okay people it's a [ __ ] kitchen
and it's yellow so i'm sure i'm gonna
catch [ __ ] about that all right colors
were in now they're not any sexual
encounters in the kitchen no just like
grab our ass in the kitchen by the sink
sometimes that's it stephanie any sexual
encounters in the kitchen when i'm doing
the dishes he likes to
grab my ass stick his hands down my
pants or pull him down yeah one time i
pulled him down i stuck my dick
i stuck my dick in your ass remember
yeah your hands were in the sink and you
couldn't do nothing
where was the scene of the crime at the
sink the sink she was doing the dishes
came up behind her pulled her pants down
whipped out my dick and put my dick in
her ass were you thrusting or no i just
told you what i did
okay yeah enjoy the kitchen no owners
maybe you'll take your wife's pants down
at the sink too and stick your dick in
there
don't stick your hands in that water in
the sink ronnie's around
anyway we ended the tour in ronnie's
living room where he was reminiscing
about the [ __ ] he received in there
whatever you see here in the living room
and dining room is going with us pretty
much if these walls could talk what are
some memories you have i don't know
we never did anything in here except a
couple of blow jobs on the chair were
you sitting down
sitting down it's their
theater chairs they recline so i was
sitting here and stephanie was sitting
here this was the good old days in the
beginning
you know when everything is new you know
she was sitting in the chair with me and
uh somehow my dick wound up out and she
was playing with my dick for a while and
then she blew me in the chair that was
it it's just a wonderful story goodbye
house it was fun
while it lasted and now it's time to
move on to bigger and better things a
new life
i agree with that a new life where i'll
melt into the sidewalk according to
certain people
we told ronnie to say goodbye to
different items in his house and then we
put it to a song as he said his
farewells hey ronnie
you're moving to las vegas
anything in your house you want to say
goodbye to
yeah goodbye to that armoire over there
with the mirrors on
it the armoire goodbye to the tv that's
not going so long tv
goodbye ceiling fan which i hate
[Music]
ceiling fan
i hate the ceiling fan why do you ain't
the ceiling fan because all it does is
move hot air around it gives you a
[ __ ] draft on your neck getting old
your bones are creaking
anything else you want to say goodbye to
you goodbye tablecloth i [ __ ] hate
you go [ __ ] yourself tablecloth
i've hated you from the day you've been
on the table i never wanted you i'm not
going to miss you at all and i can't
wait to rip you up and throw you in the
garbage
here's the tablecloth that i'm going to
rip up i ate makes you sick yeah i'm
gonna throw it away and that's gonna be
the end of it i ate the tablecloth okay
go [ __ ] yourself tablecloth go and [ __ ]
yourself okay tablecloth goodbye to the
whole house i can't wait that's it
that's it and i'm throwing it out go and
[ __ ] yourself okay tablecloth go [ __ ]
yourself tabletop
yeah that's called go [ __ ] yourself
tablecloth
ronnie's new hit song
you